seventy years after Allied bombing
reduced Dresden to rubble the Church of
the Virgin Mary stands once more the
house of worship is a proud symbol of
reconciliation it was the center point
of commemorations attended by 1,400
guests including German President
Joachim Gauck via listen we know who
started the murderous war we know and so
we do not want to forget the victims of
German warfare and never will Ferguson
we remember by commemorating the German
victims here today the entire city
played a part in the memorial events
dozens gathered at this rail Depot to
remember the deportation of Dresden's
Jews to concentration camps some here
were young children at the time we were
not bombed out memories of what happened
is still present today the fundamental
question of war and peace remains the
prime question of our time
I remember them vividly small brown
packages like pieces of burned meat
about this big we'd never seen anything
like it before we all wondered what they
were then there were bodies wrapped in
blankets their lungs were burst or they
were dead from smoke inhalation you see
the bodies sitting somewhere look like
they were sleeping
those were some childhood impressions
and after that a different life began
when bonking ein and los libros
up to 25,000 people died during the
Allied bombing raids on Dresden 70 years
later the memories live on
you